the movie begins with a quick scene from
8,000 BC somewhere in the North African
desert as a local tribe sleeps in the
dead of night a giant spaceship lands
nearby blowing away all the rudimentary
hay Huts while everyone else runs away
in fear and confusion a young man
curiously makes his way up a small helic
to see what's the commotion about
suddenly a blindingly bright light
descends from the spaceship right on the
man and engulfs the young man the scene
shifts to Giza Egypt in 1928 had where
archaeologist Professor Paul Langford
and his daughter Catherine are making
their way into an excavation site near
the Great Pyramids among the helter and
Skelter they discover a large round
cover Stone a kind of stone used as the
final piece in masonry Works marked with
hieroglyphs meanwhile young Catherine
sees a beautiful brass locket with the
eye of raw inscribed on it and takes it
with herself when her father calls her
nearby they see several excavation
workers pull up a round metal ring
marked with all kinds of symbols and of
unknown purpose the scene shifts once
again to present day 1994 where a much
older Catherine travels to find
egyptologist and linguist Daniel Jackson
who is giving a presentation on the
fourth dynasty of Egypt Catherine sees
Daniel Express his doubts on whether the
Pharaohs built the pyramids however his
audience made up of traditional Egypt
experts laugh at his suggestions and
leave before the session ends Catherine
who is still wearing the locket she
picked up all these years ago offers are
recently evicted and increasingly
alienated Daniel a shot at putting his
life together by inviting him to
translate hieroglyphs in the following
scene we see two US Air Force officers
arrive at the home of retired Colonel
Jack O'Neal in a tragic incident his son
had accidentally shot himself with
Jack's pistol because of which he fell
into depression and his marriage became
strained the two officers notify O'Neal
that he has been reactivated and his
duty on the order of General West we
then are transported to a secret
military installation in Creek Mountain
Colorado where Jackson meets other
scientists working on the mystery of the
giant coverstone odd by the size and
mystery of the cover Stone he is
informed that the cover Stone has two
parts the inner part with hieroglyphs
that they have already translated and
the outer part which is marked with
symbols yet to be decoded Jackson
quickly corrects the translation that
the other scientists have done and the
reveals that it refers to something
called the Stargate however the team of
scientists is interrupted by Colonel
Jack O'Neal who informs them that the
information now falls under US Air Force
classified project and will be
overlooked by him within 14 days Jackson
decodes the unknown symbols he finds out
that the markings on the outer track are
actually star constellations placed in
an order forming a map these
constellations form the Sixpoint
coordinates that marks a destination
point in space he then reveals that the
seventh symbol two humans praying on
either side of a pyramid upon whose head
the sun is directly pointing symbolizes
the origination point with Colonel
O'Neal's permission he is then shown the
Stargate the metal ring that was found
in Giza in 1928 a team consisting of
scientists and military personnel then
align the coordinates that Jackson
provides them with the markings in the
inner rotating track of the Stargate as
soon as the seventh coordinate is
aligned a wormhole opens in the Stargate
with tremendous ferocity the military
then sends in a remote controlled probe
to examine the Wormhole but it gets
pulled in and gets sent to a distant
planet in a far away helium Galaxy with
data sent by the probe the scientists
deduct that the planet's atmosphere is
exactly like that of Earth the full
picture is now clear the Stargate here
on Earth is one door and a two-door path
way and the other door is placed in some
far away planet Across the Universe the
symbols that Jackson decoded were the
keys to the door however Colonel Jack
O'Neal suggests that they might have to
abandon exploring this Intergalactic
Stargate because they wouldn't know the
codes to open the door on the other side
when they want to return Jackson jumps
into the conversation and says that he
can help with that and despite Colonel
O'Neal's reservations General West
invites Jackson and the team to explore
the Stargate the next day Catherine
gives Jackson the necklace with the eye
of Rob before he joins a team of seven
army men O'Neal Riley poro Freeman Brown
faretti and Kowalski to explore where
the Stargate takes them after a dizzying
and fast-paced travel they reach the
planet on the other side quickly
scanning their surrounding they realize
that they emerged within a Great Pyramid
which is the exact copy of the Great
Pyramid of Giza and is situated in a
desert the enigmatic Colonel Jack O'Neal
orders Jackson to prepare to open the
Stargate of the side but since there is
no huge coverstone which has the symbols
unlike back at Earth Jackson says that
they would need to look around so
Colonel Jack O'Neal orders his men to
set up camp near the pyramid a little
later Jackson who is sitting away from
the group sees a large camel-like animal
with a harness attached chomping at a
lonely Bush he approaches it but is
dragged away accidentally when the
animal feels threatened seeing other
members with guns O'Neal Kowalski and
brown chase after him across the desert
a while after the animal stops into the
surprise of Colonel O'Neal they discover
some kind of a mine in a distant where
humans are laboring he discovers that
the miners have seen them and hence
calls to the remaining soldiers at the
pyramid to secure it as they might be
caught here for a while as they approach
the large group of miners are stunned to
silence seeing humans like them but with
completely different attire however on
seeing the amulet with the eye of raw
that Jackson is wearing they think that
the earthlings are emissaries of the god
and bow down to them meanwhile Brown
investigates the mineral they are mining
and finds out that it is quartz soon the
chieftain of the tribe cassif arrives on
his camel like animal Jackson realizes
that they are conversing in some ancient
form of Egyptian but cannot understand
it he offers them a kind of liquid and
in return Jackson offers them a
chocolate bar which the chieftain
absolutely loves and invites them into
his City Jackson insists that this is
the chance to look for the symbols that
would open the Stargate and brown adds
that the readings suggest that the
mineral they are mining here is the same
mineral that is used in making the
Stargate in response Colonel O'Neal
radios the remaining soldiers at the
pyramid and tells them to secure the
area as they might be caught up here for
a while in the following scene we see
the long file of miners making their way
across the desert to their Village
Jackson is being treated as a deity by
the villagers once they reach the
village chafon cassif reveals to them a
giant metal plate with the eye of raw
and everyone bows down Jackson
recognizes the symbol a d begins to ask
about raw it can be seen that there is a
real fear of the Egyptian son God Among
the villagers but before Jackson can
inquire further a horn blares from the
top of the gate and to this cries of the
earth people all the villagers start
running indoors the massive main gate of
the village is also closed much to the
annoyance of Colonel O'Neal the colonel
storms towards the gate and Kowalski
grabs a villager and points a gun at his
head while Colonel fires several warning
shots the chafon teenage son Scara steps
forward and asks Colonel to follow him
up the gate which he suspiciously does
there he shows the colonel an oncoming
Sandstorm because of which the village
is being sealed the communication with
the base team is also choppy due to the
storm and the base team is forced to go
inside the pyramid that night as the
storm rages outside a party is hosted
inside the gates of the village and
Daniel tries some weird looking animal
which fortunately tastes like chicken
urged by the colonel he then goes to
cassif and tries to ask him about the
eye of raw by drawing the symbol on Sand
however as soon as he begins scrabbling
cive quickly erases it with his leg and
Jackson realizes that writing is
forbidden here Jackson is then mobbed by
a group of old ladies that take him to a
room and SC rub off his hands and feet
clean soon after cassif offers his
daughter shye to Jackson who initially
declines it but seeing how it may be
taken as an insult to her he pretends to
accept her slowly he begins to
communicate with her through symbols
that he draws on Sand which he initially
thinks she wouldn't be comfortable with
however shye then draws the same a
circle over the pyramid symbol that he
saw on the Stargate and he asks her to
show it to him meanwhile at the base
camp in the pyramid the faretti Freeman
poral and Riley are getting impatient
waiting for for the others they cannot
turn the Stargate on by themselves
because there may be infinite number of
combinations which may send them to any
random Planet hence they are stuck here
suddenly with a massive quake and sound
the ship of raw lands on the pyramid
before the soldiers can muster up any
kind of Defense poro and Riley are
killed while faretti and Freeman are
captured on the other hand in the
village Colonel Jack O'Neal is slowly
making bonds with the tribesmen he gifts
gar the lighter who is absolutely
fascinated by it but when the young boy
reaches out for his gun O'Neal
uncharacteristically lashes out at him
perhaps haunted by the memory of his
dead son in the meantime shy takes
Jackson down to the caves and shows him
various symbols painted on the Walls by
naming the symbols on the walls and
matching it with the names that shy
gives them Jackson slowly starts to
learn their language step by step when
Colonel Jack O'Neal Brown and Kowalski
find him he reveals the story that the
symbols told him Ra was once a part of
an alien race whose home planet was
dying and the species themselves were
becoming extin inct unable to prevent
his bodily Decay raw traveled across the
universe until one day he stumbled
across a planet teaming with life i e
Earth there in 8,000 BC according to
Earth's time scale he possessed the body
of a young man as we saw in the very
first scene of the movie with his
advanced technology raw was able to
subjugate the people in ancient Egypt to
maintain the constant supply of the
mineral that fueled his technology and
prevented him from dying raw transported
humans from Earth to abidos to work in
the mines however the the ancient
Egyptians protested against him and
managed to overthrow his overseers and
ultimately burying the space gate never
to be found out to prevent this from
happening at a bidos raw forbid reading
and writing while Jackson is explaining
all this to Colonel O'Neal Kowalski
finds the cage that contains the symbols
to open the Stargate however when
Jackson sees it he finds that the
portion that contains the seventh symbol
has been worm out and alible at the same
time they cannot establish any kind of
contact with the base team despite the
radio signals was working just fine so
they decide to go back to the pyramid
after a brief firefight with the
overseers of raw which results in Brown
being killed Colonel O'Neal and Jackson
are held captive and taken to face raw
raw Reveals His in his overseas humanoid
form for the captives he then proceeds
to display the nuclear bomb that Colonel
O'Neal brought with him in case of dire
extremes while everyone is distracted
Colonel grabs the gun from one of the
overseers and shoots all the guards
before pointing it at Raw a moment of
hesitation takes over the colonel as raw
is surrounded by small kids taking
advantage an overseer overpowers him and
throws him in the jail in a horrible
turn of events Jackson is killed in
Cross Fire unbeknownst to them a group
of youngsters led by Scara has followed
them to the pyramid and are observing
all this ra then takes out his anger on
the poor villagers by sending out his
fighter jets and indiscriminately
shooting and bombing the village which
leaves several wounded and dead this
fuels a fire of rebellion among a group
of tribesmen meanwhile at the pyramid
raw puts the dead body of Jackson in a
sark of Gaz like chamber and brings him
back to life however he is not doing
this as a show of respect or love but to
make an example out of Jackson through a
vicious punishment the next he orders
the tribesmen to gather around the
pyramid where he forces Jackson to kill
his other teammates however Jackson
notices a group of the tribesmen led by
scarl hiding guns that they got from the
abandoned suitcases of earthlings
suddenly Jackson turns around and shoots
a beam at the ground raising dust and
giving enough time for captives to run
away sadly Freeman is killed in the fire
from raw's overseers the earthlings then
find refuge in a cave along with the
Villagers who are now in open Rebellion
against raw Jackson informs Colonel that
his nuclear bomb will be sent to Earth
through the Stargate along with a
shipment of the minerals which will make
the explosion 100 times more destructive
Colonel admits that the plan was for
everyone to return back while he would
stay behind to detonate the bomb and
completely wipe out any sign of Danger
on aidos Jackson urges the colonel to
not give up on his life that easily deep
into the night Scara is drawing a
victory sign on the wall and Jackson
realizes that it is the seventh symbol
as it is very similar to the seventh
symbol of the Stargate at Earth O'Neal
and his surviving men join forces with
Scara to overthrow the remaining
overseers now free from their oppressors
they launch an attack on Roth who orders
his fighter ships to engage the humans
while his own ship prepares to depart
the humans outside fight bravely but are
eventually forced to surrender when they
run out of ammunition however seeing
their gods as they truly are mere
mortals and spires the rest of the tribe
to rebel against their guards shye
tragically loses her life in the
conflict but Jackson manages to smuggle
her body aboard raw's ship using a
teleportation device Left Behind to face
raw's Guard Captain annabis O'Neal
engages in a fierce battle meanwhile
Jackson uses the Regeneration device to
bring shye back from the brink of death
just as they are discovered by raw
O'Neal activates the teleportation
system sending Annubis to his demise and
allowing Jackson and shye to escape with
the hero's re United they teleport the
bomb onto rw's ship destroying it and
vanquishing the evil God with their
mission complete and the humans freed
the remaining team O'Neal Kowalski and
faretti return to Earth Jackson however
chooses to stay behind with shye and
start a new life with his Newfound
family